water hyacinths may look pretty but they
create problems over the past few
decades the invasive and pernicious weed
has been choking Nigeria's waterways and
lagoons it's become a serious problem
for fishing communities along the rivers
fishermen like it all YCO doubt or are
in despair we come all the way from
Macomb and when we get here we can't
find any fish to catch they all hide
among the water hyacinths when we cast
out nuts they get caught in the weeds
the plants were a great nuisance for us
it seems there's no way to get rid of
this invasive plant it has no natural
enemies here and it's spreading
unhindered in this foreign ecosystem it
all has just learned that he can harvest
and sell these weeds to a social
enterprise I don't even have money to
cut my hair or to shave it's these water
hyacinths now that I discovered I could
sell by I'm going to sell them all the
plant thrives in warm climates and in
water with low levels of salt in Lagos
lagoons it doubles in size every two
weeks before it's not a blessing to me
the collected water hyacinths end up on
a channel a de Chavez doorstep in a
baton in 2009 she left her corporate
career in the US and created the eco
enterprise Mitte meth here she turns the
alien plant into a thriving business
discovered and actually originated from
the Amazon people thought it was an
ornamental plant because of this
beautiful purple flower that we have on
here but little did we know it was far
from an ornamental plant instead it is
an invasive aquatic weed decomposing
water hyacinths pose another threat to
the climate they produce methane a
potent greenhouse gas
which has 21 times the global warming
potential of carbon dioxide thanks to a
chinos creativity these dried stems of
the water hyacinths are converted into
useable and decorative objects the
processing is cheap and simple
after three to four days we have it in
dry form 95% of that water has
evaporated and what we have now is 5% of
dry weights we transform in two ways we
either flatten the weed and use it for
things like maths and notepad covers or
we make rope from it the transformation
takes place at her factory a channel
helps the community by creating job
opportunities through innovative
handcrafted products in the past two
years they harvested and processed more
than 25 metric tons of water hyacinths
and turned them into art pieces for sale
that was a hyacinth was not completely a
problem without the solution there are
actually several solutions and also the
several solutions that I discovered a
zeroed in on handcraft simply because I
like hand crafts and I also figured that
if I was going to profit this solution
it has to be a solution that people
could relate to training and regular
workshops within the communities are key
components of a channel success the weed
based products range from furniture to
lamps and personal accessories the
turnover in 2010 was just $20 it's risen
to $25,000 today primarily from domestic
sales 140 kilometers north of Lagos
adoro hopes for a better livelihood them
all off they disturb us these water
hyacinths they disturb us a lot
there are many of us suffering from this
we're many way to many not a single one
of us can find any fish anymore but now
adobo was your daughter and his fellow
fishermen have hope
even though they're still struggling to
find fish to support their families the
water hyacinths are not as threatening
as they were before they've become a new
source of income